When do you forgive? When someone asks
for forgiveness and they've repented.
But not a fake forgiveness. A
forgiveness that bears fruit. Because
one sign of
repenting is to turn away. So when they
truly repent and ask for forgiveness,
that's when you forgive here. Black and
white.
Black and white.
Right here.
Black and white, man.
So let me explain to you bad teaching.
When people tell you forgive those
who've offended you depends on what they
mean. Let me teach you the correct
theology of scripture.
Let me explain. Ready?
When they tell you forgive those who
have offended you depends on what they
mean. If they mean in your heart hold no
grudge. Ask God to release you of any
bitterness. Heal your heart. Yes. But if
they mean tell the person you forgive
them, that is the stupidest, most
unbiblical advice you can be given. You
know why? I'm going to give you
receipts. Let me just elaborate on this
so we can go into the topic.
The Bible does not tell you forgive
those who don't ask for forgiveness.
The Bible says you forgive when they ask
for forgiveness. Okay. Luke 17 3-4.
Okay, here it is. Let me repeat. The
Bible does not say to tell someone, "I
forgive you who haven't who hasn't asked
for forgiveness."
Okay? So, if someone tells you forgive
those who sin against you, that if they
mean in your heart, ask God to heal you
of bitterness,
to release you of any bitterness and
hatred so it doesn't eat you up for your
own health. Yes, Lord, heal me in my
heart. Not to hold bitterness and hatred
to let go of that and forgive that
person in my heart. Yes. Do you know
why? Because
if you hold a grudge and you continue to
be bitter, it will damage you, not the
person. Let me just again, let's speak
facts and I'm going to give you
receipts.
Bitterness,
anger,
rage
that you cling to will destroy you
physiologically
because ask doctors. Number one killer
is stress. When you are bitter, you
affect yourself physiologically. You do
physical damage. You get sick. In fact,
it can even lead to cancer. let alone
what it does to you psychologically and
let alone what it does to you
spiritually. Because if there's that
hatred and anger that you simmer in, it
will affect your relationship with God
because God won't be pleased with you.
And then it will consume you
psychologically, emotionally so that you
can no longer have healthy relationships
because you're too focused. You're too
entangled in bitterness. And then it
manifests in your relationships. It
comes out cuz all you're going to be
talking about is that bitter hatred and
the people around you won't want to be
around you because they don't want to be
stressed anymore than they already are.
So it's for your inner peace. It's for
your health spiritually, emotionally,
physiologically that God says let it go.
So, yes.
Are you with me there? Yes.
You with me there.
It actually does cause disease, cancer,
and other physical ailments. This is a
medical fact. The Bible even says that,
right? You'll find in the book of
Proverbs, you're told like Jesus Christ
reign says, "When you have bitterness,
it rots the bones.
Okay, so that's true. But if they mean
to tell you, go and tell the person you
forgive them. That's stupid advice. And
I'm going to explain to you why. First,
let me give you the biblical basis. Luke
17:es 3 to 4.
Okay? Learn from the Bible. Be on your
guard. If your brother sins, rebuke him.
If he repents, forgive him. See the
condition? If he or she acknowledged
they've sinned and they turn from it,
then you forgive him or her. Well, what
if they haven't repented? What's there
to forgive?
And if he sins against you seven times a
day, a returns to you seven times
saying, "I repent. Forgive him." Notice
repentance in the scripture is not only
acknowledging your sin, but turning away
from it.
So, what did our Lord say? When do you
forgive? when they turn away and
acknowledge their sin to you.
You understand?
Is that sinking in?
Proverbs 28:13.
He who conceals his transgressions will
not prosper. You see, don't hide, Lord,
please forgive me, Lord, and be honest
and open with you.
You hide it,
you won't prosper. But he who confesses
and forsakes them, that's the condition,
will receive compassion. Right?
And I'm going to show you the wisdom.
And only forgiven a person who
acknowledges they've sinned and turned
away and ask for forgiveness. And here,
still don't believe me. All right? Still
don't believe me? Even God himself,
brethren, you don't
you don't believe me. God does not
forgive those who don't ask for
forgiveness.
You know that
God does not forgive those who don't ask
for forgiveness. Because if he just
forgave you without asking it, no one
will be in hell.
Right?
No one will be in hell.
If God
does forgive people
without them asking for forgiveness,
everyone goes to heaven.
Right?
And where am I getting this from? The
words of our Lord.
Matthew 18:21-35. Then Peter came and
said to him, so let me get this out of
the way.
Lord, how often shall my brother sin
against me and I forgive him up to seven
times? There was a rabbitic tradition
saying you should forgive him three
times.
And Peter saying, look, I'll outdo the
rabbis seven times. She said, "No,
that's not even enough. I do not say to
you up to seven times, but up to 70
times." Meaning, leave the door for
forgiveness, recon reconciliation wide
open. Don't put a limit to forgiving
someone who asks sincerely to be
forgiven. But at the same time, you're
not stupid and naive and gullible
because you have to distinguish if it's
true repentance or is it simply lip
service that's not from the heart.
Now here again, if you don't think I'm
being biblical, I'll give you the
receipts right here from scripture.
For this reason the kingdom of heaven
may be compared to a king who wished to
settle accounts. Okay, watch
with his slaves. When he had begun to
settle them, one who owed him 10,000
talents, enormous exorbitant amount that
you cannot pay off in a lifetime,
right? I believe if you were to tally it
in modern currency, this would probably
be in the billions.
In other words, humanly impossible
payoff.
That's the debt this man owed to the
king. And the king is gone. And your
debt is sin. But since he did not have
the means to repay, his lord commanded
him to be sold along with his wife and
children and all that he had and
repayment to be made. Therefore, the
slave, now notice, when does the king
forgive
the debt and pardons him? The slave fell
to the ground and was prostrating
himself before him, saying, "Have
patience with me and I'll repay you
everything." Feeling compassion, the
lord of that slave released him and
forgave him the debt. So he took a hit,
a sacrifice,
right?
But that slave went out and found one of
his slaves who owed him 100 dinari. A
dinar, I believe, was a day's wages. So
in comparison to the impossible debt
that he owed God, meaning impossible to
pay, this guy owed him peanuts. It was
like peanuts, dude.
You see the great debt God forgave you
that you could not pay off. And you're
going to refuse to forgive someone who
in comparison to the debt you owe to God
owes you peanuts.
And he sees them again choke him saying,
"Pay back what you owe." So his fellow
slave fell to the ground was pleading
with him saying, "Have patience with me
and I'll repay you." This is the Lord's
prayer. Forgive us our trespasses as we
forgive those who trespass against us.
Here it played out in a parable. You
want God to forgive you, you better
forgive those who ask for your
forgiveness. So just like he asked the
Lord
right here
prostrating before the king who is God
have patience I'll repay you everything.
Now that servant's servant did the same
thing.
He too fell to the ground played with
him. Have patiently I'll repay you. But
he was unwilling and went and threw him
in prison until he should pay back what
was owed. So when his fellow slaves saw
what had happened, they're deeply
grieved and came reported to the Lord
all that had happened. Now watch. Then
summoning him, his lord said to him,
"You wicked slave, I forgave you all
that debt." Notice why? Because you
pleaded with me. See that? That's the
condition.
God doesn't just forgive you.
You have to ask and plead and God
forgives you. So where does you where do
you get in the Bible go up to a person
say I forgive you who hasn't asked for
forgiveness? What are you in drugs?
So why did God cancel the debt forgave
him? Because you pleaded with me. Should
you not have mercy on your fellow slave
in the same way that I have mercy on
you? Cuz he too pleaded with you. And
his lord moved with anger handed him
over to the torturers until she should
repay all that was owed him. My heavenly
father also do the same to you if each
of you does not forgive his brother from
your hearts. But what's the condition?
If your brother pleads with you like
when you plead with me and I forgive
you. Do you catch it here?
And let me tell you the wisdom of it.
What's the wisdom here?
Do you know what someone will say to you
who doesn't admit they have sinned
against you or offended you or betrayed
you but think they're justified in what
they did to you?
You know what that person will say to
you say I forgive you. They'll say
forgive what? You need to apologize to
me. I need to forgive you. Forgive me
for what? It's your fault that I did
what I did. If you didn't admit me, I
you know, they'll they'll they'll laugh
at you or be offended. Forgive me.
Forgive me for what? You're at fault.
It's because of you.
So, how stupid is it
to go and say to someone, I forgive you,
who does not acknowledge their sin
against you.
Has it has nothing to do with
humbleness. has to do with often times
people who have sinned against you,
betrayed you, offended you. They justify
what they have done. They don't
acknowledge they've done you wrong. They
blame you because they say if you hadn't
done X, Y, and Z, they wouldn't have
done what they did.
So, where the hell
is the forgiveness when they don't
acknowledge they've sinned against you
and don't want your forgiveness blame
you for what they did?
I mean, come on, common sense.
And you guys who've been through it,
tell me right now by confession when you
went to someone who betrayed you,
backstabbed you, or
cheated on you,
and you go and say, "I forgive you."
Those individuals who didn't even admit
they did you wrong, but blamed you for
what they did, just on what they did,
because it was your fault. Because if
you had met up to their standards, they
wouldn't do what they do. When you
forgave them, what was their reaction to
you?